meantime other news here at five with  the second dose now available some of  you have been asking is it okay if i  schedule my second dose  a few days maybe before or after the  target date here's what health leaders  told us  the cdc actually supports there is a  little bit of  flexibility from that like in particular  21 day timeline but also for the for the  28  and they give essentially two days prior  and two days after  as what we refer to as like the sort of  the open window  sort of the ideal window there so you  have to wait three weeks remember  before you can get your second pfizer  dose and then  four weeks if you got the moderna shop  don't worry if you can't get an  appointment in exactly three or exactly  four weeks  the best practice is to get that second  dose just as close to that target date  as you can but it still has good effects